[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes lundi à 19
septembre vous regardez le sécher les
invités merci de nous rejoindre au
programme de cette émission de quoi
inviter trois témoignages rencontre avec
louis burton le skipper originaire de
rambouillet participe pour la deuxième
fois au vendée globe nous livrera ses
ambitions pour cette compétition et en
plateau avec nous ce soir annie couteau
la présidente du club de baseball des
cougars de montigny le bretonneux elle
reviendra sur la finale de playoffs de
l'équipe seniors une chance pour le club
de remonter en d1 et enfin du 10 au 25
septembre la consommation locale est
mise en avant avec mon agent local en
ile-de-france un moyen de mettre en
lumière les agriculteurs les artisans et
les restaurateurs qui soutiennent la
consommation locale témoignage de
nicolas l'ont guère responsable de la
production a l'habitude tri rtg
perray-en-yvelines
et de la voile pour commencer nous vous
en avions parlé la semaine dernière la
course du vendée globe approche 3
skipper originaire à des épines
participeront à cette édition 2016 parmi
eux il y à louis burton le navigateur
âgé de 31 ans est originaire de
rambouillet et participe à son deuxième
tour du monde sans escale et sans
assistance le 6 novembre prochain notre
journaliste sportif michael et me
d'euros la rencontre et regardez on est
quasiment quasiment trente au départ au
début l'organisateur avait limité à 27
le nombre de bateaux et puis finalement
ils ont ouvert parce qu'il y avait plus
de demande que d'offre de place donc
c'est bon signe et puis après au niveau
au niveau de la course c'est en tant que
coureur ben c'est super intéressant ça
fait un plateau très diversifié il y a
[Musique]
un niveau de compétition qui est très
élevé et en même temps plein de
rencontres
et une ambiance un petit peu différente
vous aviez abandonné lors de précédentes
éditions vous pensez terminé la course
cette fois ci c'est l'objectif alors on
ne peut pas dire qu'on pense terminer la
course parce que c'est c'est il ya une
dimension aventure donc l'entreprise
dont la fin n'est pas certaine sur le
vendée globe il ya à peu près 1 50 % de
la flotte qui abandonnent chaque édition
c'est un peu la statistique ce qui
prouve que
on
peut vraiment se passer plein de trucs
les moyens modernes ne permettent pas de
deux
limiter cette case d'empêcher les
abandons et tout donc ça veut dire que
c'est à dire qu'on peut espérer finir
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
vouloir terminer et pas forcément
terminée bon j'ai pas pu terminer la
dernière fois donc j'espère bien que
cette fois ci ça pourra le faire et que
la malchance sera ailleurs est-ce qui
est une formule pour terminer la course
mettre toutes les chances de son côté ça
veut dire avoir le limiter le risque de
le casse technique parce que c'est un
sport mécanique donc avoir une bonne
préparation et puis en sport automobile
on dirait éviter la zone rouge quoi il
faut respecter le matériel faut se
respecter aussi physiquement pas se
faire trop mal palais se mettre aussi
soir en zone rouge et puis je ne sais
pas pour les croyants
aller prier et puis pour les athées
juste veiller et puis et puis faire
attention à tout ce qui se passe à tout
l'environnement vous visez une place
particulière cette année vous juste de
terminer la course
j'aimerais j'aimerais être
j'aimerais raisonnablement être entre
cinq et 10e de l'épreuve ce serait ce
serait une vraie réussite pour moi vous
êtes 3 illinois cette année sur le
vendée globe il y a également éric
bellion est en vie de la motte comment
expliquez vous qu'il y ait autant de
skippers yvelinois sur une course si
importante
peut-être parce que le peut-être parce
que les
les yvelines en tout cas la partie que
je connais moi donc qu'ennuyé la forêt
de rambouillet et c'est
d'ailleurs tchèque à tous les rangs
politiques
et est en fait au sud de paris assez
orienté à ses tournées vers finalement
vers la mer quand on quand on veut aller
en bretagne on passe on passe dans les
yvelines avec l'autoroute a10 quand on
veut aller par la mer via la normandie
on passe aussi dans les yvelines avec
l'autoroute a13 et peut-être que
culturellement c'est une région qui
abrite des gens qui soient plutôt ouvert
au monde et peut-être peut-être qu'ils
qui aime voyager plus que plus
qu'ailleurs on continue à parler sport à
présent et notamment de baseball et de
la finale des play-off de la deuxième et
division pour cela nous recevons en
plateau avec nous annie couton
présidente du club de baseball des coûts
guerre de nom il brode on saura vous en
soit on vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous jouez les
premiers matchs de la finale avec
l'équipe senior le week-end prochain la
première division se rapproche toujours
les premiers matches oui nous devons
nous déplacer à saint-just-saint-rambert
puisque les final de d2 se joue en 5
matches et le gagnant sera celui qui
aura remporté les trois matchs donc nous
allons faire deux matches à
saint-just-saint-rambert et le week-end
d'après nous recevons pour le troisième
voire le quatrième ou le cinquième match
si besoin nous espérons nous arrêter au
troisième set vous attendiez à atteindre
un tel niveau c'était notre objectif
donc nous avons atteint notre objectif
nous avions en début de saison nous
avions dit que nous voulions atteindre
les finales donc nous y sommes arrivés
maintenant notre objectif est de gagner
la finale et ensuite ce sera de
remporter le match de barrage contre le
dernier de la d1 puisque ce il faut
passer ce barrage là pour voir aller en
d1 si j'en crois mon collègue et des
sports michael me d'euros votre
qualification est un peu rocambolesque à
notre édification était curieuse puisque
nous étions à la fin de la saison
régulière nous étions sûrs de jouer les
demies les demi finales donc nous
devions pour cela nous étions deuxièmes
du championnat régulier nous devions
pour seul arrêt rencontrer l'équipe de
la rochelle et puis les quais l'équipe
qui était première est l équipe fédérale
de toulouse et ils ont déclaré forfaits
sont dit qu'il ne jouerait pas les demi
finales n'est pas la finale donc nous
nous sommes retrouvés premiers du
championnat régulier et à devoir
rencontrer le cinquième qui était
eysines et eysines a aussi déclaré
forfait car il avait des problèmes et de
joueurs et des problèmes financiers donc
nous avons été qualifiés en finale sans
avoir joué de demi-finale alors comment
ça va se dérouler les prochains week end
que comment vous allez vous vous
organiser une préparation spécifique à
bien la préparation oui c'est à dire que
les joueurs ont repris l'entraînement
fin août il espérait pouvoir quand même
faire leur match de demi finale pour
pouvoir avoir du jeu avant d'atteindre
la finale et c'est vrai que la b se sont
entraînés nous n'avons pas pu avoir de
match puisque toutes les autres équipes
étaient déjà occupés nous n'avons pas pu
avoir deux matches donc ils se sont
entraînés dans un batik senteurs et sont
allés s'entraîner à frapper mais pour le
moment nous sommes un peu dans
l'expectative quant à la qualité du jeu
des joueurs puisque ça va faire depuis
le 3 juillet n'ont pas fait de match
c'est un handicap quand même ça pour
vous c'est un handicap mais justement
quelque part aussi c'est quand on part
avec un handicap ça donne de la force -
ya plus de fraîcheur ou ici c'est un peu
cette année ou jamais la deux le monde
de se qualifier ça faisait longtemps que
j'attendais ça oui on attend ça depuis
on avait ça fait deux ans qu'on échoue
en demi finale donc nous nous étions dit
c'est l'année où jamais puisqu'elle
apparemment l'année prochaine les
championnats d' d2 vont être modifiés ou
en deux poules de six et donc ou en deux
poules de cinq on n'est pas encore tout
à fait au courant donc ça ne nous
convenait pas tout à fait d'emploi notre
objectif c'est vraiment de retourner en
d1 après il ya l'aspect financier et il
va falloir trouver
des
sponsors qui va être encore plus
difficile puisque aller en d1 ça va il
va falloir que nous achetons nous
faisions venir trois étrangers donc
c'est vrai que cette année nous n'avions
qu'un c'est déjà un sacrifice est là
cette année l'année prochaine si nous
voulons concurrencer les autres équipes
il nous faudra trois étrangers du coup
on va faire appel à plus de sponsors
allait peut-être des marchés elle va
falloir aller démarcher oui oui faire
démarrer il va falloir aller faire du
porte à porte il va falloir aller
démarcher mais bon ça on va prendre les
problèmes les uns après les autres nous
allons d'abord gagner la finale après
nous allons gagner les barral et après
nous verrons pour trouver du financement
le but c'est de se maintenir après
forcément en première division parce que
voilà on voulait pas faire l'intérieur
c'est pas ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est de
se maintenir en première division et de
pouvoir enfin garder nos jeunes qui
souvent bas partent dans les haies qui
dans les autres dans les autres équipes
qui sont en d1 et peut-être récupérer
nous avons déjà eu des discussions avec
des anciens qui avaient été à mon unique
sont partis jouer dans des équipes de
dés 1 qui nous ont dit que si nous
allons d'ailleurs et que vous arrivez à
nous maintenir je reviendrai chez nous
d'accord ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et
par rapport aux joueurs étrangers du
coup les mercato commençait à se passer
alors ben quand nous allons faire nous
allons savoir si nous sommes en d1 nous
allons commencer à regarder il ya des
sites spécialisés sur internet justement
nous allons nous avons un joueur que
nous avons quelqu'un qui s'occupe de ça
qui va aller regarder faire le marché
pour voir ce qu'il y a comme joueur sur
le marché qu'est ce qu'ils ont comme
exigence parce qu' ils ont pas bon nous
avons de la chance par rapport à
d'autres clubs parce que nous sommes
proches de paris et donc nous avons plus
de chances que par exemple que clermont
ferrand ou que des clubs qui sont pas
pour montpellier de la chance parce
qu'il est au bord de la mer mais nous
avons quand même plus de chances de
récupérer des joueurs car tu as quand
même nous sommes très proches de paris
après la falloir voir ce que demande au
point de vue financier il ya une
certaine aura attractivité dernière
question avant de terminer cet entretien
si vous gagnez le week-end le week-end
prochain vous avez prévu un bus voilà
qui il rassure la venue du centre et
commencent à se lasser non nous n'avons
pas encore prévu de nous préférons
attendre que nous allons voir ce qu'ils
font la semaine prochaine à
saint-just-saint-rambert après nous
avons peut-être prévu de faire des tee
shirt champion de france des choses
comme ça mais le bus venait du santon
peut-être peut-être que les fans aux
fruits en tout cas que les fans ne
feront remis nous espérons le premier le
samedi 1er octobre
remplir deux tribunes y aura de
l'animation il y aura une tombola
nous espérons avoir beaucoup
d'animations dont les à l'abord de la
dernière finale en 2008 nous avions
rempli des tribunes donc là nous
espérons faire aussi bien eh bien on
vous souhaite bonne chance et nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur cet événement
assure tv fil 78 merci admettre qu on va
parler consommation locale à présente du
10 au 25 septembre pour les semaines du
mangeons local en ile de france les
agriculteurs les artisans et
restaurateurs qui soutiennent la
consommation locale vous ouvrent leurs
portes corinne fans est allé à la
rencontre de nicolas longuet il est
responsable de la production de la
biscuiterie rt opéré en évident je vous
propose de l'écouter on a un label qui
s'appelle saveurs équipe de france on a
été auditée qui on doit avoir un certain
nombre de matières premières qui soit à
proximité notre entreprise et le fait
aussi de fabriquer en ile de france
opère en yvelines à côté de rambouillet
donc on peut on fait travailler
effectivement des partenaires locaux
pour une question éthique
et puis c'est beaucoup plus sain
effectivement que tu es revenir des
produits de loin pour éviter une du
carbone dans l'environnement et donc on
va accentuer cette démarche
parce qu on y croit et que
et que c'est plutôt logique de consommer
des produits locaux plutôt que de
consommer les produits hors saison qui
ne seront pas forcément locaux qui
viennent de l'eau bout du monde et donc
c'est beaucoup plus sain et puis de
faire travailler des gens localement
aussi
donc tout ça c'est beaucoup plus un dans
le temps et perrin que de fabriquer des
produits à l'autre bout du monde les
rapatriés qui est voilà donc là on
essaye de faire travailler du monde et
puis essayer de
d'utiliser au maximum les ressources
naturelles de notre région les gens sont
de plus en plus soucieux de savoir d'où
vient le produit ou s'est fabriqué le
fait de nous localiser ils peuvent venir
on a une boutique qui est ouvert du
lundi au vendredi de 14 heures à 18
heures où on vend des produits voilà
7h30 le kilo peuvent venir nous voir la
fabrique est juste derrière la boutique
donc ce qui permet quand même que les
gens associent le produit ou ses
fabriques et qui c'est qui fabrique
voilà on reste on essaye d'être de
rester le plus directe aux consommateurs
pour
pour que le consommateur identifie notre
produit à nous qui on est qui sait
qu'ils fabriquent les matières premières
et c'est à présent la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
demain vous retrouvez à wilfrid est
enrichie pour le 7 8 et les invités je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur les
vérifier ce sont 18
[Musique]